[Música]
bueno
estamos obsesionados con la felicidad y
no es de extrañar porque nos machacan
hasta la saciedad con esto de que
tenemos que ser felices
para lo cual ya nos ofrecen recetas de
todo tipo y para todos los gustos
mindfulness coaching psicoterapia
positiva literatura de autoayuda
fármacos del bienestar aplicaciones de
la felicidad para teléfonos móviles e
incluso frases de optimismo impresas en
camisetas y en las tasas del café
y todas estas recetas insisten en el
mismo mensaje y nos hacen la misma
promesa
que ser feliz es una elección y que
cualquiera podemos serlo porque es muy
fácil ya que poco o nada tienen que ver
nuestras circunstancias pues la
felicidad es simplemente un estado
mental y una cuestión de actitud y de
voluntad
vamos que parece que no tenemos excusa y
que hoy en día si no somos felices es
porque no queremos más si cabe cuando
los denominados científicos y expertos
en bienestar afirman haber descubierto
por fin las claves de la felicidad y de
la buena vida
sin embargo cada vez son más las
investigaciones que ponen en duda la
veracidad de estas afirmaciones y que
documentan las consecuencias negativas
de todos estos mensajes y de estas
promesas y es que razones para dudar de
este discurso de la felicidad no faltan
empezando por que esto de que se han
descubierto las claves para que seamos
más felices lo hemos escuchado una y mil
veces antes pues supuestos descubridores
de la felicidad ha habido muchos a lo
largo de la historia especialmente en
eeuu que es donde debemos situar el
origen cultural de todas estas ideas y
de estos mensajes también porque los
usos políticos económicos e
institucionales que se hacen de la
felicidad no son ni mucho menos
inocentes y no siempre van en nuestro
mejor beneficio el ámbito de las
empresas es un buen ejemplo de ello
porque las empresas especialmente a las
más grandes esto de la felicidad les ha
venido tan bien para disfrazar ciertas
formas de control y de explotación
laboral de positividad y de crecimiento
personal que uno diría que de no haber
existido de la felicidad serían las
propias empresas quienes la habrían
inventado
de hecho no es casual que las empresas
estén tan interesadas en la felicidad
que inviertan en ella más de 45 mil
millones de euros al año a nivel global
eso sí quizás invirtiendo más en la suya
propia que en la de sus trabajadores
pues si bien hay empresas que se
preocupan de buena fe por el bienestar
de sus empleados sería algo ingenuo por
nuestra parte pensar que lo que hace
felices a los trabajadores es
exactamente lo mismo que lo que hace
felices a las empresas
pues a pesar de la enorme inversión que
hacen las empresas en este sentido las
últimas encuestas revelan que más del
70% de los trabajadores estamos
estresados y estamos insatisfechos con
nuestros trabajos y con nuestras
condiciones laborales
también hay razones para dudar porque el
mensaje de que quien no es feliz es
porque no quiere esconde al menos un
lado perverso
y es que si la felicidad es una elección
personal
entonces el sufrimiento también lo es y
por tanto quien sufre es o bien porque
quiere o peor incluso porque se lo
merece ya que no estaría haciendo todo
lo que se supone que está en su mano
para evitarlo quienes no hemos escuchado
alguna vez esto de que la depresión la
ansiedad o incluso la enfermedad nos la
provocamos nosotros mismos con nuestros
pensamientos negativos o con nuestro
pesimismo es un mensaje perverso como
digo porque una vez entramos en su
lógica en realidad no nos queda mucho
margen para la elección sino que estamos
obligados a ser felices o al menos
aparentarlo aunque sólo sea en defensa
propia porque como cada vez más estudios
señalan al respecto hoy en día el
declararse infeliz o no lo
suficientemente feliz tiende a
experimentar sea entenderse cada vez más
como un fracaso propio
como un signo de debilidad personal o
como el resultado de una vida emocional
mal gestionada por nuestra parte y por
supuesto también hay razones para dudar
de este discurso de la felicidad porque
detrás de todas estas promesas lo que
hay en realidad es más ideología que
ciencia y mucho más negocio que
simplemente buenas intenciones un
negocio inmenso además pues hoy en día
la felicidad no sólo se vende
literalmente sino que se vende muy bien
tal y como muestran las cifras
astronómicas que maneja esta industria y
donde tan solo la venta de libros
prácticos sobre la felicidad genera más
de 120 millones de euros al año en
españa y más de 15 mil millones
alrededor del mundo
y de este negocio y más concretamente de
la felicidad como producto quería
hablaros un poco más en profundidad y
aquí
decía según bauman con ironía que en el
mundo actual todas las ideas de la
felicidad terminan en una tienda
lo cual es cierto pero creo que la
cuestión principal es que en vez de
entrar la felicidad parece más bien
salir de las tiendas
es decir que parece estar ya pensada ya
diseñada desde un inicio para circular y
para ser consumida como una mercancía
porque si hay algo fuera de todo
cuestionamiento es que la felicidad ha
demostrado ser un producto redondo y
enormemente rentable es muy barato de
producir es muy sencilla de suministrar
y genera enormes beneficios económicos
para todo aquel que la ofrece y es que
al final va a resultar que no eran las
claves de la felicidad lo que habían
descubierto
sino las claves para vendernos y con
esas y que parecen haber dado y en el
clavo
además
y cuáles serían estas claves habría
varias pero me gustaría señalar al menos
cinco de las que considero que son las
más importantes y que están relacionadas
entre sí
la primera de estas claves es insistir
en que esto de la felicidad está basado
en la evidencia y que los productos que
nos ofrecen están científicamente
probados
también es importante que todos estos
productos vengan aderezados con una
buena dosis de términos propios de la
neurociencia y cuanto más mejor
y digo aderezados porque en la mayoría
de los casos el uso de estos términos en
relación con la felicidad se hace de
forma muy poco rigurosa muy poco precisa
aunque nos impresionen que es
precisamente el efecto que pretenden
conseguir con ellos no tanto el de
informar o el de explicar sino el de
funcionar como un argumento de autoridad
el problema es que la ciencia que hay
detrás de la felicidad ha demostrado ser
una ciencia bastante débil
por lo que no está nada claro que el
recurso a la ciencia en estos productos
vaya más allá de ser una mera estrategia
de marketing
la segunda clave es insistir en que la
felicidad es algo que necesita
ejercitarse y de continuo además
quizás la metáfora más recurrente al
respecto y que seguramente muchos
habremos sabido es que la felicidad es
un músculo en un músculo cualquiera si
no un músculo emocional que necesita
ejercitarse de forma constante ya sea
porque el músculo es débil y necesita
entrenamiento o porque sea fuerte y
requiera mantenimiento la cuestión es
que para ser felices debemos asumir este
ejercicio emocional como una rutina o
como un hábito
la industria de la felicidad se
ofrecería aquí como una suerte de
gimnasio emocional que pondría a nuestra
disposición toda clase de entrenadores
cualificados de herramientas de
ejercicios y hasta de suplementos
necesarios para que trabajemos de
continuo el músculo de nuestra felicidad
cultivando cuestiones como nuestro
optimismo nuestro pensamiento positivo
en nuestras propias fortalezas
psicológicas como las denominan
siguiendo con la metáfora se genera aquí
un curioso y problemático perfil que en
alguna ocasión es denominado el
vigoréxico emocional
qué son estas personas por un lado
obsesionadas con el tamaño de suyo
de su autoestima con su crecimiento
personal con su florecimiento y por el
otro lado con una visión distorsionada
sobre sí mismas donde nunca se ven a sí
mismos como los suficientemente fuertes
o musculadas en términos emocionales
hagan lo que hagan y se ejercite en lo
que se ejercitan
relacionado con esto una tercera clave
es dejar entrever que la felicidad es
algo insaciable un camino siempre por
recorrer hacia una meta que no llegamos
nunca a alcanzar
porque según los expertos no importan
los satisfechos que ya estemos que
siempre podemos ser más felices la
felicidad nos recuerdan con frecuencia
no es la ausencia de malestar sino la
continua presencia de bienestar así que
ante la pregunta de iu cuando somos lo
suficientemente felices la respuesta es
nunca
esto genera una paradoja
importante interesante y es que según la
cual
la industria de la felicidad nos promete
completa satisfacción y realización
personal y sin embargo lo que hace es
producir y nutrirse de un relato
que nos dice que esta satisfacción y
realización personal sólo pueden ser
parciales o incompletas en el mejor de
los casos pues siempre hay algo que
hacer o algo que mejorar de cara a la
felicidad
siempre hay un pensamiento negativo que
eliminar un hábito más positivo que
adoptar una fortaleza que desarrollar
una capacidad que optimizar un yo más
auténtico que descubrir lo cual es
perfecto para una industria que se nutre
de vincular está perpetua búsqueda de la
felicidad está insaciabilidad constante
con el consumo perpetuo
y se genera aquí otra otro curioso y
problemático perfil que algunos han
denominado el buscador de la felicidad y
que yo prefiero llamar el happy con
draco
qué son estas personas que ya van a
terapia no porque estén objetivamente
mal sino porque querrían estar mejor de
lo que ya están
digamos que se sienten insatisfechas y
hasta cierto punto vacías por no
sentirse como por no ser todo lo felices
que creen que podrían llegar a ser
una cuarta clave es insistir en que la
felicidad es algo no ya que se aprende
sino que se enseña
si bien resulta paradójico que pueda
enseñarse algo que no se sabe muy bien
que es y que carece de una definición
consensuada al respecto es sin embargo
lógico desde el punto de vista del
producto pues de no aprenderse
difícilmente podría vincularse la
felicidad a la necesidad del ejercicio
emocional constante y de no enseñarse
difícilmente podría justificarse tanto
el papel del experto en bienestar como
la existencia del producto mismo pues
nadie compramos estos productos por mero
entretenimiento sino precisamente para
que nos enseñen cuáles son las guías las
recetas los pasos las claves para ser
más felices
llama sin embargo la atención
una meta tan supuestamente elevada y
compleja como es la felicidad pueda en
realidad conseguirse a través de medios
tan simples como los que acostumbran a
ofrecernos que sí haciendo unos cuantos
ejercicios de gratitud que si meditando
dos veces al día que si escribiendo unas
cuantas frases positivas en un papel o
que si leyendo este libro o acudiendo a
esta charla que te cambia la vida
pero claro en su simplicidad reside la
quinta de estas claves y es que los
productos de la felicidad tienen este
atractivo de ofrecernos soluciones
simples e individuales a problemas que
son más bien complejos y estructurales
el mensaje de que el secreto para lidiar
con nuestros problemas se halla en
nuestra interior es sin duda tentador
por la sensación de control y de
empoderamiento que podría generar nos
sin embargo esto tiende a desdibujar el
hecho de que gran parte de los problemas
que estos productos prometen resolver
pongamos por caso la ansiedad la
depresión o el estrés
no son única o principalmente problemas
de naturaleza psicológica sino que son
más bien problemas de tipo estructural
relacionados con cuestiones como la
desigualdad la incertidumbre económica
la inestabilidad laboral
a corto plazo sin duda algunos podríamos
encontrar útil el acudir a un curso de
mindfulness el contratar a un coach o el
leer un libro de autoayuda para lidiar
con la ansiedad que padecemos en el
trabajo
pero a medio o largo plazo no vamos a
resolver con ello un problema cuyo
origen y mantenimiento se explica
frecuentemente mejor por cuestiones de
precariedad
de competitividad o de sobrecarga
laboral que por cuestiones de una mala
gestión emocional
en este sentido los productos de la
felicidad pecan de generarnos la ilusión
en ambos sentidos de la palabra de que
es muy fácil cambiarnos a nosotros
mismos para mejor de que es simplemente
una cuestión de actitud y de fuerza de
voluntad
pero por desgracia esto no es tan
sencillo y creérnoslo puede generarnos
mucha frustración además de sentido de
culpabilidad pues al fin y al cabo puede
que ni sea tan fácil cambiarnos a
nosotros mismos ni que podamos resolver
ciertos problemas como los que he
mencionado sin que cambien las
circunstancias que de hecho los originan
o que los mantienen
pero si hay una clave principal de todo
este negocio esta puede resumirse ni más
ni menos que al enorme éxito que ha
tenido toda esta industria en que
normalicemos la obsesión con la
felicidad
porque aquí la cuestión no es que seamos
o que no seamos felices tanto como que
estemos constantemente preocupados por
si lo somos o por si no lo somos
que estemos constantemente ocupados en
perseguir esa felicidad prometida bajo
el convencimiento además de que existen
y de que alguien tiene las claves
científicas para más inrri para
encontrarlas lo cual como insinuaba
anteriormente no parece ser el caso
quisiera enfatizar diciendo que esta
charla no es un alegato en contra de la
alegría de las sonrisas de la esperanza
o a favor de la tristeza tampoco es un
alegato en contra de toda forma de
felicidad posible es más bien una
invitación a cuestionar esta forma de
felicidad tan individualista tiránica y
sobre todo consumista que industria que
empresas y que además científicos y
expertos en bienestar promueven y de la
que quizás sean ellos los más
beneficiados
es una invitación a poner en duda esta
felicidad con la que hoy en día
parecemos estar obsesionados y yo diría
que no para bien
así que para terminar me gustará y como
viene siendo habitual en este tipo de
charlas y escenarios
me gustaría finalizar la mía con un
mensaje positivo
y es que como de las obsesiones como de
las adicciones como de las desilusiones
o como de los desengaños la buena
noticia es que de la felicidad también
se sale
[Aplausos]